So maybe this becomes
clear with an example so
we go back to the Pac-Man example,
at all times you want to eat ghosts, eat
dots, eat big dots, and avoid ghosts.
It's sort of all happening
at the same time.
It's just at any given point in time
one of them happens to be ascended.
>> Okay, yeah that example
makes more sense to me than
in the navigation example.
>> Sure, but I think conceptually
they're the same it's just it's easier
to think about it.
In fact we actually have a name for
these kind of things,
we call them predator-prey scenarios.
>> Who's we?
>> You and me.
So here-
>> No, no, no I don't call them that.
>> Yes you do this is a pretty, yeah
well okay the literature is replete with
examples of things called predator-prey.
Where you basically want to go around
eating as much as you can, but
there's some predator
who's trying to you.
So you're always trying to eat,
because you have to eat or
otherwise you die of starvation.
But you have to avoid a predator
otherwise you die while the other one is
not dying of starvation.
And Pac-Man is just
an example of predator-prey.
Right?
Pac-Man
needs to eat all of these things.
Meanwhile there are predators out
there trying to eat it and so
they're kind of competing goals
happening at the same time.
I need to eat,
I need to avoid being eaten.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Right?
And
all of these are really
examples of that,
they even use the word eat and
avoid them.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I need to eat my food and
at the same time I need
to avoid being eaten.
And occasionally because I live
in a magical world where suddenly
rabbits become as big as wolves,
I can occasionally the wolf.
>> I see.
>> Right, but once you think about it
that way you can stop thinking about,
I mean, so I'm not trying to
make a gigantic point here.
Other than we can think about actions
as actions we're executing or
we can think about these options as
things that are accomplishing goals.
And this is where goal abstraction
comes from in my title here.
That really all of these options
are about accomplishing different goals,
you're trying to always
accomplish those goals.
Some goals are more important
others at any given point in time.
And options in fact really make this
sort of nice to think about because
of beta.
Because beta captures sort of
the probability that we might terminate
in a state.
>From this sort of goal obstruction point
of view you could think about this as
either the probability that I've
succeeded in executing that option,
that is I have accomplished my goal.
Or that another goal has
become important and
I need to interrupt whatever goal I
was paying attention to at the time.
>> That makes sense.
>> Right.
So I like this notion of thinking about
options, or thinking about actions
as always accomplishing goals and
always sort of happening in parallel.
Options are easier to think about than
primitive actions that way because
in fact when we define the options I
think we sort of naturally think of them
as accomplishing goals.
That's sort of the whole point.
And primitive actions are sort of so
low level they don't really have,
other than primitive goals like
moving left or moving right, they
don't really have big high level things
that they're trying to accomplish.
But options almost always do, that's why
they're useful and that's why people
tend to come up with the ones they tend
to come up with, so it seems to me.
And so we think about managing
goals then we actually end up
with a different way of
thinking about this problem.
And we move from a world where
we're worrying about sequencing and
hierarchical abstractions to a world
where we think about managing and
arbitrating between goals.
Yeah, so let me write down different
ways you might do that because
it turns out there's a whole
subfield that worries about
thinking about the problem this way.